JENNY BROWN: What do we want?
Data.
And where do we want it?
In buckets.
In this episode of
Cloud Storage Bytes,
we take a look at
buckets and why
they are the cornerstone
of everything you do.
Stay tuned for more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before you can do
anything in Cloud Storage,
you've got to create a bucket.
Because anything
you want to store
in Cloud Storage needs a
bucket in order for you
to do anything with it.
When configuring
your bucket, you
need to make three
initial decisions--
name, location,
and storage class.
First, a bucket needs
a globally unique name,
and this can't be changed.
So choose a name that will be
relevant and useful to you.
We've got great
documentation on naming,
so we'll go ahead and link
that in the description.
Once you've named your bucket,
you need to select a location.
You should choose location
based upon what type
of redundancy options you need,
where your primary users are,
and what your expected
first time to byte
is when caching is turned off.
Generally, you should
store your data
in a location that's convenient
or contains the majority
of the users of your data.
There are three different
types of locations--
region, dual-region,
and multi-region.
This gives you
plenty of flexibility
in choosing the location
that will work best for you,
since location can't be changed
once that bucket is created.
Use a region to help
optimize latency and network
bandwidth for data consumers,
such as analytics pipelines
that are grouped
in the same region.
Use a dual-region when you want
similar performance advantages
as regions, but you also want
the higher availability that
comes with being geo-redundant.
And use a multi-region
when you want
to serve content to data
consumers that are outside
of the Google network
and distributed
across large geographic
areas, or when
you want the higher availability
that comes with geo-redundancy.
And finally, you
choose a storage class,
which you can update
later on, but if you
don't select anything initially,
this will default to Standard.
Let's dive in and see
what that actually means.
Cloud Storage has four
different storage glasses.
All offer low latency
and high durability,
but they vary based
on their availability
and minimum storage durations,
along with the pricing
for storage and access.
Data that will be
served at a high rate
with high availability should
use the standard storage class.
This class provides the best
availability with the trade
off of a slightly higher price.
Data that will be
infrequently accessed
and can tolerate a
slightly lower availability
should be stored using
the nearline storage,
coldline storage, or
archive storage classes.
Your choices here are
going to vary depending
on your specific needs.
I like to think about using
nearline for something I'll
access once a month or so,
and archive for something
I'll need about once
a year, and coldline
for the stuff in between.
The documentation will help
you make the best choice here.
Now that you know what
goes into Cloud Storage
and where it goes, we'll
get to the good stuff,
like how to get it there
and what to do with it.
Until then, subscribe,
give us a like,
and let us know what features
of Cloud Storage you'd
like to learn more about.
Thanks for joining us for this
Quick Byte of Cloud Storage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]